taproot upgrade is here bitcoin just got
better this is a brand new era for
bitcoin but you are probably asking
yourself what the hell is taproot well
don't worry that's why you watch the
show because we've got your back to
understand taproot you first have to
understand who the market participants
are with bitcoin there are three
specific market participants that are
worth mentioning for this conversation
first we are going to start with the
developers the developers obviously are
the folks who are writing code they are
responsible for creating and updating
the code they are there for contributing
to the software database they write code
and they go ahead and they contribute
that code to the code base the miners
are there because they are there to
secure the network miners secure the
network by using computing power to run
the bitcoin network they get paid from
the block reward 50 bitcoin to every 10
minutes then 25 and 12 and a half then
6.25 that's how the miners work and then
lastly we have the full known operators
full node operators they are the
backbone of the cryptocurrency network
these folks are there to validate send
and receive blocks and transactions and
maintain a copy of the blockchain so in
a quick synopsis we have the developers
we have the miners and we have the full
node operators now why is that important
well because when the code changes when
there are upgrades these three people
come into play first the software
developers they actually write the
software that is going to be the change
that is accepted or not accepted the
second is the miners who get to actually
secure the network but everyone forgets
it's the node operators they are
ultimately the judge the jury and the
executioner the node operators decide
which version of the software they want
to actually run or not so with that said
we have to understand there's two types
of updates they are called forks
software forks there's a hard fork and a
soft fork and a hard fork first is an
ability to change the code but that new
code is not compatible with the old code
this is a very aggressive change this
means that if i said hey we can handle
10 transactions and then all of a sudden
i was to expand that and i say now we
don't actually accept 10 transactions we
can actually do 15 transactions well any
block that had 15 transactions would not
be compatible with the old blocks that
can only accept 10 transactions so it's
an aggressive change that is not
compatible moving forward tech that is
why it's called hard fork it's hard it's
aggressive it's very different that
would not allow you to be compatible
with the old code a soft fork is very
different a soft fork is a change to the
code that is still compatible with the
old code so you can still run the old
code and be in compatibility with the
new code and vice versa so hard fork is
aggressive big change soft fork is less
aggressive not nearly as big of a change
the hard fork versus soft fork
fundamentally both above types of forks
serve different purposes contentious
hard forks can divide a community but
planned ones allow the freedom to modify
the software with everybody in agreement
that is what a soft fork is everybody in
agreement to modify the software
soft forks are a gentler option
generally speaking you're more limited
in what you can do as your new changes
can't conflict with the old rules that
said if your update can be crafted in
such a way that it remains compatible
you don't need to worry about
fragmenting the network so this comes
from the binance academy definitions
very good hard fork versus software soft
fork is agreement of everybody and it's
a gentler option that allows you to make
the changes that don't come in conflict
with the old changes that is what we are
watching with taproot upgrade so the
taproot description from bitcoin
magazine taproot is a combination of
many different bitcoin improvement
proposals of bips resulting in a soft
fork of bitcoin's blockchain so taproot
is a soft fork it's a gentle option it
has agreement of everyone it is a
proposed upgrade that over time is
adopted as the only blockchain meaning
that the old one will cease to operate
once the new one taproot is fully
adopted now what exactly is inside the
taproot upgrade what is the actual
things that are happening we've got two
different descriptions the first one
coming from bitcoin magazine a little
bit more technical in nature the first
major point is around this snore
signatures right it's a very technical
component but what you have to
understand is that you're able to do
things around key and signature
aggregation you can take a bunch of
different signatures and put them
together rather than have them be
individually identified provide superior
security and it can batch verification
so step one schnor signatures step two
is taproot itself this was a separate
bitcoin improvement proposal taproot
itself ends up showing us that there are
a couple of different aspects to this
bitcoin script update paid to taproot
and mast these allow for certain types
of compatibility with the schnorr
signature so taproot and schnorr
signatures kind of go together and then
the third thing is around smart
contracts and around those smart
contracts something called tap script
tap script actually allows us to look at
the collection of opcodes which are
essentially just lines of code that
execute commands on the bitcoin protocol
that have been updated to make way for
the new changes installed by taproot
really really complex in terms of
execution but when you simply look at it
it allows for much more expressiveness
and much more composability with bitcoin
this brings us closer and closer to the
ability to not just use bitcoin as a
pure payment system but to actually have
it do other things and that is why
people are very excited so if we go
ahead and we look at cnbc not such a
technical uh update mackenzie sigulos
had a great overview this weekend she
wrote a big part of bitcoin's makeover
has to do with digital signatures which
are like the finger print on individual
leaves on every transaction it won't
translate to greater anonymity for your
individual bitcoin address on the public
blockchain but it will make simple
transactions indistinguishable from
those that are more complex and
compromised of multiple signatures so if
we think exactly what does this mean
your public bitcoin address does not
change in terms of uh whether it's more
has more anonymity or not but what does
change is that a simple transaction will
be indistinguishable from something that
has much more complex and complicated
signature structure so it provides more
privacy in a very specific way she went
on to write
that
uh
in practice that means greater privacy
because your keys won't have as much
exposure on the chain you can kind of
hide who you are a little bit better
which is good this comes from brandon
arvanani who is a bitcoin mining
engineer and who runs meow on top of
that we then have the smart contracts
these are souped up signatures that are
also a game changer for smart contracts
which are self-executing agreements live
on the blockchain the smart contract
could theoretically be used for
practically any kind of transaction from
paying your rent each month to
registering your vehicle taproot makes
smart contracts cheaper and smaller in
terms of the space they take up on the
blockchain and uh colleen uh said that
they are enhanced functionality also
that currently smart contracts can be
created both on bitcoin's core protocol
layer and on the lighting network a
payments platform built on top of
bitcoin which enables instant
transactions these smart contracts
execute a lightning network typically
lead to faster and less costly
transactions so when we go ahead and we
look at this the big takeaway for the
taproot upgrade is that there are three
separate big components to it there is
the signatures there is the tap script
itself and also you have the
compatibility with the schnorr
signatures when you look at it from an
everyday person the only thing that
matters is that there is more privacy
and more usability coming to bitcoin
that ultimately is good for bitcoin so
if you hold bitcoin you like the fact
that it is improving that it is evolving
that it is getting better and better
over time